We are following developments
in Ukraine, where officials
say Russia has launched
a new round of missile and drone attacks
Several regions in the east
were targeted,
including de Dnipropetrovsk,
where more than two dozen
people have been injured,
including three children.
A top Ukrainian commanders says 15 of 18
cruise missiles fired
by Russia were intercepted.
And a Ukrainian official
in Kiev
says the country's air defense forces
destroyed Russian missiles
in the airspace above the capital.
Funerals were held in the Ukrainian city
of Oman, barely a day
after a missile strike
killed 25 people
in an apartment building.
Yes, because this week, many of your
impressions of all
the family and residents say farewell
to a brother and sister
who died in that attack.
Ukrainian President
Volodymyr Zelensky said
the government will do everything
it can to hold accountable
the people responsible
for killing innocent civilians.
CNN's Nic Robertson spoke
with residents of the community
who were paying their respects
in the shadow of death.
There is love, floral tributes and toys
for victims of Russia's strike in Uman Fri
Anna.
15 years old,
is paying respects to her near neighbors.
So many innocent children died, she says.
I'm so sorry.
They're not alive anymore.
More than a day after the apartments
destroyed, recovery winding down.
25 dead, six of them children.
Victoria points
to where her father lived.
This one was with the blue wall here
they are overseas.
She lists all the neighbors
who are now dead.
On the ninth floor,
a grandma,
her daughter and two great grandchildren.
On the eighth floor, a father and son.
On the seventh floor,
a mother and daughter, my best friend.
And on the sixth floor, a young couple.
Both 33 of them.
Her father survived.
It was a miracle, he says.
They rescued me with a ladder
and people gave me clothes.
Victoria
shows us documents
a letter to a now dead friend.
The photo of another neighbor
she tells us she found them
blowing in the wind.
This is so important, she says.
They're all that's left.
The recovery is painstakingly slow.
The wait for answers about the missing
just as painful.
But in all the grief, there is humanity
and there is anger
in a nearby school.
Neighbors sought clothes,
a gift for survivors who lost everything.
We saw all this family, the children.
They were crying.
And I don't know.
We just felt
that was something
we need to do to help them.
We feel hate for our
Russian neighbors,
if we can call him like that.
But most we are focused on helping just
only happen.
Police already
documenting the scale of the loss.
Boris BOF
telling them his vehicle destroyed.
It's not what's been destroyed
that matters, he tells us.
It's the lost lives.
We sent photos of the destruction
to our distant relatives in Russia
so they can see what their army is doing.
They didn't reply, he says.
All around, life is being
put back in some sort of order.
The broken, patched up.
But ask anyone about repairing relations
with Russia.
What do you think about about Russia now?
Animals
Imagine that for the next generation.
Russia's attack.
A life shaping memory.
Nic Robertson, CNN, human.
Ukraine.